it is great to welcome to the program
today heidi begosian who's a new york
city-based attorney and author whose
latest book is i have nothing to hide
and 20 other myths about surveillance
and privacy uh it's really great having
you on i appreciate your time
thank you david great to be here so
let's start historically a little bit if
we can
was there sort of a surveillance state
before 911 and the patriot act and the
bulk surveillance that we've learned
about over the last decade or so what
was there an apparatus that predated
that and to what extent
there has always been a surveillance
apparatus in the united states and the
justification for it remains the same
it's largely based
on the government's
uh
theory that we need to be monitored to
protect national security
and i think what we've seen with the
events of 911 but also as the digital
age has really
taken over our lives
we've seen that surveillance apparatus
on steroids in effect
and the ways that we can be monitored
are just about as many as one can
imagine and we're seeing so many levels
of creativity to do that from spying on
children
to just invading all aspects of our
daily lives
let's talk about some of the methods i
guess because people may not be familiar
with all of them i think
metadata is a term that many more people
now are familiar with maybe than they
used to be in this concept of well even
without the content of a phone call
uh a list of the numbers you've
interacted with can be very uh
revealing and invasive when it when it
comes to observing your activities but
can you talk a little bit about the
breadth of these techniques and
technologies that are in place
an easy way to look at the extent to
which we are monitored is to think of
the gold rush of the early days of this
nation
we're in a data rush right now
and data represents uh essentially the
crude oil that fuels our digital economy
so
every time you log on we have third
party we have data aggregators which is
more than a 200 million dollar billion
dollar business in this country
so if you think of it
as your personal information
is like nuggets of gold that others want
to reap collect as much as they can
essentially without the laws
sort of like the property laws that
didn't exist when we had the early gold
rush
our legislators
have not kept up with tech advances
so that um facebook for example just
announced that it was putting the pause
on developing
uh an app an instagram type app for kids
right
which really habituates not only young
kids to become
loyal users of that app but it allows
third parties to gather personal
information it may be
just what sites they visit
what preferences they have when they
purchase something online or when they
ask their parents to buy something
each of those kernels when put together
can give a really accurate profile
of our lives and you mentioned
metadata well metadata is defined very
loosely as information about information
so it's sort of
when a photo might have been taken it's
kind of embedded in all of the documents
that we get online
that when captured in large quantities
and having algorithms applied to search
for patterns in that
can really tell a lot about who we are
for example if i went to a cancer doctor
five times in one week or an abortion
provider
those
that information is then sold to others
including government agencies but
largely marketers and for-profit
entities who then design ads to target
us to buy more of a similar product
or to send us
ads about cancer treatments and
medications the problem is when you get
faulty algorithms
as we so often do
and one example was drone strikes that
this country launched in afghanistan and
other countries from 2006 on
there were flawed algorithms which means
that in that case there were lethal
consequences people who really shouldn't
have been on a terrorist watch list for
example may have been killed in drone
strikes innocent individuals
right
um there's kind of two layers on which
we could talk about the security aspect
of
the surveillance state one would be does
it make us
quote safer
and if it did we could then have a
debate about the trade-offs and whether
that's worthwhile so maybe we can start
with the first piece do do we know that
these techniques put in place starting
around 9 11 and going forward does this
increase safety in any measurable way
there's been no evidence to prove that
it does increase safety and that's
really a tragedy because i think
millions
of americans
may think they're doing the right thing
by saying i have nothing to hide you can
have my data uh but i think it was the
navy war college uh issued a report
years ago saying that they had analyzed
uh so-called threats of terror
terrorists and found that the measures
put in place after 9 11 which really
cut back on a lot of our liberties uh
and certain constitutional rights that
we take for granted they found no
evidence
that it made us safer in any instance
and i think the problem is most people
don't know that it's not publicized
because
in addition to bolstering the claim that
it does make us safer what it ultimately
does is hand over information that gives
more control to those in charge and that
means less autonomy in our personal
lives and more controlled by others
now
if it let's talk about i have nothing to
hide maybe maybe a little bit um a few
years ago i mean that seemed pretty
reasonable to me you know my feeling was
yeah i i get that there may be people
who know more about me than i would
willingly give up
but i don't have any particular reason
to worry about this because i don't have
anything to hide and then i read about
over-criminalization about how sometimes
you may not think you have anything to
hide but you may inadvertently have done
something or interacted with someone who
does maybe have something to hide uh and
then all of the other pernicious ways in
which this can be used what's the
best sort of argument against that idea
of i really don't care i don't have
anything to hide
i think a fundamental argument against
that is that people need to realize the
importance that privacy has played in
this society
for example during the aids epidemic
uh
a lot of health care providers hotlines
realize that in order to help quell the
spread of hiv
they would need to offer anonymous
reporting or anonymous testing
um
and that's true in so many other
segments so for example a woman who has
been the victim of uh spousal abuse
has to know if she's going to come
forward to seek help that she can do so
anonymously or privately and there are
different levels of how you shield one's
identity but that pertains to
whistleblowing in government to uh
encourage people to come forward when
they see malfeasance in the institutions
in which we put our trust so i think you
have to first start it privacy plays an
essential part in society and then you
have to realize that
if you're willing to hand over your
entire life to the government
we do so because we trust the government
and i think you know that's a wonderful
premise of which to base a democracy but
we have seen in fact that we cannot
always trust our leaders that
self-interest or other factors may lead
them to abuse our information or very
often just due to a casual mistake my
name may be confused with a similar name
i may be mixed up with someone who did
commit a crime for example but because
of the databases
that all of our information is stored in
contains so many errors often just
sloppy data entries that there have been
so many cases of people caught up
in a crime that had nothing to do with
their lives and they were falsely
prosecuted it also shows that if the
government doesn't like what you say if
you're a dissident or just an outspoken
individual who criticizes a corporate
policy for example or a government
policy they can target you and find just
about any reason
among the many antiquated laws that are
on our books to go after you
yeah that i just am i'm almost done
reading this new book the perfect police
state about china and the persecution of
the of the uyghur population
is there a spectrum in the sense of it
it seems in terms of surveillance china
is very much on one end
what's on the other end and where on
that spectrum is is the united states in
your assessment
that's an excellent question we do look
to china as an example of the extreme
and what we as a
purported democracy would never want to
be where for example i just have to say
they have a system that is being used in
some parts of china where
you're under such constant surveillance
that if you jaywalk for example or if
you don't pick up after your dog points
are deducted yes and that can you know
reflect the electricity you get the
access to social services
on the other extreme and that's a great
question because i can't really think of
a nation
um so many of our partners in the
so-called five eyes new zealand canada
the uk have sort of rings of
surveillance everywhere it's become the
norm and we're becoming uh conditioned
to just accept that but i would imagine
there are probably countries in
scandinavia or countries maybe in latin
amer south america where
the technology
in some of those countries may not be uh
sophisticated as what we have here with
our robust economy so i would imagine
that in countries without that kind of
surveillance accessibility you don't
have the digital surveillance we have
here and so
where is the us on this spectrum right
now in your assessment
i think the us is pretty high up there
with england for example as basically
having the equivalent of these what we
call rings of steel the the
circles of surveillance cameras closed
circuit tv but we have it built into our
economy so that
as simple as getting a cup of coffee may
have a loyalty card where they track
the numbers of coffees that you buy but
they also track more your credit card
number which is linked to other data i
think that the us is in a race to
perfect total information awareness the
collection and with the entry of 5g
where more things will be even connected
and when they're internet connected
that provides near-perfect access to our
data i wonder let me see how i can kind
of frame this up i wonder if there's a
degree of inevitability to this because
of the direction
not from a law enforcement standpoint
but from a socio-cultural technology
standpoint if there's a degree of
inevitability to some of this and i'll
give you like one example and then we
can talk about it
the entire literature now around
longevity and living longer healthier
lives and nano medicine and customized
med
it's mostly all premised on
having much more data not only about you
as an individual
but data about how you compare to others
and what sort of diet or supplements or
treatments or whatever the case may be
good for you specifically there's really
no way it seems to do this stuff without
many more parties having access not only
to our individual data but to
everybody's in some sense and for the
most part i mean in some kind of like
general sense a lot of that stuff sounds
kind of interesting like it would be
great to know what exact diet or what
exact preventive treatment so is there
some inevitability to this that is going
to be hard to restrict at all
i think that's absolutely right uh
first
we have convenience uh then we have the
kind of addictive quality that these
devices have and they're created in
effect just like video games to be
addictive yeah but there are as with all
technology so many positive benefits as
you mentioned and i think the trick is
harnessing those but also
having an educated public
that is able
to realize when
they should have the option of saying i
don't wish to share that and i think the
problem that we're having and why i
wrote this book sort of is a primer so
people could get a sense of the
different areas
that were impacted by is
we need to first our legislators have to
be more educated about technology
they're
woefully behind
the advancements and that's a problem
because they can't craft laws that keep
a pace with new technologies that are
emerging daily and new applications so i
think
if we have a program where we educate
kids the first time they learn to type
on a keyboard what the perils are and
what the benefits are
and really develop a healthy uh
course in school that parents also
participate in in digital hygiene we
would not for example let a stranger
walk into our bedroom every night and
use our toothbrush or just make
themselves at home downstairs and that's
in effect what we're doing in what young
kids are doing without that education so
i think you have to educate the public
and our leaders
to the degree
that they are able to say
we need to build in privacy for example
into our devices or the software has to
be better tested before it's put on the
marketplace to ensure that adequate
privacy protections are built into their
infrastructure last thing i want to
touch on with you if someone right now
is makes it a priority uh to prevent
themselves from being tracked watched
monitored surveilled etc you google this
and you see things like turn off
microphone access for your facebook app
on your phone right very very narrow and
specific thing all the way to
don't use banks or credit cards which
for the average participant in the
modern economy is is not at all sort of
practical um to what degree is it
possible to to really not be tracked
right now regardless of how aggressively
you're willing to adopt these things or
to some degree
if you're sort of like living on the
grid it's quite difficult at this point
in time
it's super difficult one would have to
literally not use a credit card
uh stay off online searches yeah
and and and i think what's daunting to
most people and i get it is that you
know encrypting
uh for those who are reporters or
journalists who have to protect
confidential sources there are wonderful
measures in place that they can use it
becomes more difficult for the average
citizen
to use all of those but there are basic
things like
not using the same password over
changing it using a sentence instead of
your pet's name there are basic things
that aren't that hard enabling
two-factor authentication for example
when you log into accounts uh keep down
the number of apps that you have they're
really portals unless they come directly
from the manufacturer
don't download things from online
um there are measures you can take to
reduce the amount of surveillance um i
think it's unrealistic to say you can
stop it entirely unless you go off the
grid yeah yeah
the book is i have nothing to hide and
20 other myths about surveillance and
privacy we've been speaking with the
book's author new york city-based
attorney
heidi begosian such a pleasure having
you on i really appreciate your time
today
thank you david